Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Eigentlich ist der Rasenfunk werbefrei. Aber wenn es darum geht, befreundete Podcasts zu fördern, dann darf auch hier Werbung sein. Nein, sie muss es sogar. Und deswegen hört ihr jetzt eine Ausgabe mit Jens Huiber vom Sportradio360.
Servus Max. Ich hab ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Warum?
Ich komm immer zu dir, wenn ich irgendwas an den Mann bringen möchte oder an die Frau.
Ja, aber das ist doch in Ordnung.
Okay, dann ist gut.
Meine Türen stehen immer offen. Jens Huiber, meine Damen und Herren, an den Empfangsgeräten da draußen von Sportradio360. Es ist mir eine Ehre, dich wieder im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass zu haben.
Es ist mir eine ganz, ganz große Freude, Max. Ich bin immer gerne hier, in Giesing, in den Studios, wie ich gelesen habe.
Die Studios, sie entwickeln langsam ihren Ruf.
Ja, und Charme. Und es gibt wieder diesen köstlichen Waldbeertee, den auch deine kleinen Damen, auf denen stehen sie.